hey Charles how are all right I wanted
to ask you about this Nick BOCES
situation Ohio State he decided he's
gonna shut it down he's gonna be a
top-10 pick he's a captain of the
football team and said he's gonna
prepare for the ground what do you make
of this well I think it's his decision I
think you know you I never tell people
they're wrong it's his decision I don't
know the severity of his injury you know
I don't know how much longer he was
gonna be out but I never tell people
they make the wrong decision if they
don't want to play you have to make your
own decision to live with them I
understand what these kids set out the
bowl games if it's a meaningless bowl
game and if you're gonna be a top 15
pick top ten pick or first-round pick I
understand that and even this it's a
business decision that he's risking
millions or might be risking millions to
play the rest of the season although
it's kind of tough when they built use
of the captain and you decide that
you're not going to play anymore it's
tough to be a captain but legacy how
much longer was he gonna be out is he
gonna come back for the last two or
three games yeah like I mean you have to
take in a severity of the injury and I
thought when he first got hurt they said
it was gonna be out a week and now he's
been out like a month so it's a tough
decision especially being a cap that I
agree with you all right basketball last
night 76ers in the Celtic is this a
rivalry Charles well I think for the
next well it was a great rivalry in the
80s I was privileged to be part of it
and they're gonna have to play each
other for the next ten years you know
because being in Joella both young kids
or studs antiseptics got an
overabundance of talent so yeah it's a
robbery and Toronto Raptors in that
conversation also but they're gonna be
have to go through each other for the
next ten years so I would consider the
robbery it feels like the Celtics are
just the better team and even a Celtic
team that didn't have Kyrie or Gordon
Hayward beat the 76ers last year in the
playoffs so I I don't I think we want to
make
rivalry I don't know if it's a rivalry
yet well I think the keys listen I've
said everything about the Sixers it all
won't drop down to marquel folks listen
you know Ben it's got to do this thing
you know Jill Joelle it went out and got
will come Chandler who I think gonna
really help them I'm a big Wilson
Chandler fan but you got szerik but the
keys gonna be more careful because you
can want to play against me Kyrie Irving
and in Terry Rozier they got to get
better on the perimeter and it's all
gonna be about marquel folks before it
can be like they on the same level with
the Celtics feel bad for folds for a
variety of reasons but one is every time
the Sixers play the Celtics the Sixers
are looking at Jason Tatum going hmm
that's right we we traded to get the
number one pick and bypass Jason Tatum
well you know give up on folks yet
listen you know it's so funny with us
talking heads we every time we get
something right we brag about it and I'm
not talking about you dad I'm telling
just overall when I'm watching all these
shows you remember two years ago
everybody was talking about Jericho and
a bust
yeah now he's like oh maybe we
overreacted Marcus played I'm not even
gonna count last year marking opposers
played one game this year let's don't
let's give him a chance it's a long
season
we got a 2-2 game eight in one more
games to go a lot gonna happen in the
next seven months so the jury is still
out on Marquette opposable s don't
overact
but tatum is a stud yeah yeah did you
ever have a moment where you lost your
shot or you got the yips or you you know
you went through some kind of mental
period where you couldn't shoot just
kick your ass all the time you did one
time you did one time because you cuz
you were scared to play because you know
you a coward you won't come back to
Tahoe you know Dan the closest thing I
can think about forces to what happened
to my golf game
like I'm terrified over the ball
I got no idea what's going to happen
that's the only thing I can really
compare it to so III don't want to say
he got to 100% Yelp's but I happy yes on
the golf course
and let me tell you something it's a
terrifying thing plain and simple but
you went to somebody you went to a
hypnotist right I felt really good I was
really relaxed and then I went to the
golf course they're the same crappy
swing did you go to a therapist for this
or just a hypnotist I went to a
hypnotist you know at some sporting
events they have those hypnotist so I
took to get he put on a show in Phoenix
one time and I went to LA is spent today
with the guy nice guy it's really I
guess a but I guess it wasn't his fault
but it did not work I didn't get a good
nap when I was there what is the biggest
story line this NBA regular season well
I think the Eastern Conference to me
it's the biggest story line I mean the
Warriors are the best team in the West I
think the only team that was close to
them was the Rockets and I think they
regress losing Trevor Ariza and and Luke
ma bootay I think you got the three
teams in the East the setters got so
much talent you don't know how it's
going to work you know people think just
cause you got all that talent it's just
gonna flow it's not gonna flow you got
Toronto who's really good and it's Kauai
want to be in Toronto he just paying his
dues until next year but he can go to
the Clippers other Lakers and then you
got the Sixers as you saw last night Ben
Simmons is unbelievable but unless they
get something from Mark Hill folks they
can't beat the Celtics or Toronto
so those are the three best story lines
I'm gonna be watching listen I love
LeBron he's a great player he's a great
man but the Lakers don't have a good
team they're not contenders and we can't
try to make them contenders they're
gonna be fun to watch and I think the
thing that I would want to guard against
if on the Lakers front office is that
you get some success and then you may
want to trade for somebody to help you
make a playoff push or help your
position for the playoffs and I wouldn't
do anything with that roster I would I
would let those younger guys you know be
around LeBron have them get to a point
where they're not just watching him be
LeBron where they're actually equal
teammates with him and some of the older
guys that they got let's see how they
rub off hopefully rub off in a positive
way with the younger kids but what would
what would make what what would concern
you the most about the Lakers this
season well what kind of team are they
are they gonna Plateau let those young
guys play or they go put those old guys
out there that's why I didn't understand
because those old guys are not their
future ball
who'sa Brandon Ingram that's their
future so I don't know what the Lakers
are doing are they gonna try to groom
those young guys and go forward with
LeBron or are they gonna play those old
guys I think that's what's gonna be the
most fascinating thing I mean I have no
idea what the Lakers are doing are
they're a young team or their old team
and I think that that's what I'm gonna
be watching for the most who's the first
player to be traded off the Lakers
that's a great question I don't know
because I like Ingram I like Kuzma I
like ball but like I say with all them
older guys on the bench I just I don't
know who's gonna get to play are they
gonna try to win some games with those
older guys are they trying to be up for
the future with those young guys so like
I say I just don't know yeah I'm
wondering if there's lunch so
ball going can he fit in with them with
with LeBron and and they're gonna be
up-tempo and I love that but you got a
point guard who can't shoot can't shoot
free throws so I I just wonder can you
still have him play a big role for this
team well you know what's interesting we
have a conversation last night what
Ernie talking about to differ between
Markel folks and Ben Simmons I look at
ball closer to Ben Simmons than folks he
can't shoot but he makes a big
difference in the game like Ben Simmons
can't shoot but he like but he makes it
you know he's a stud he's a terrific
player and he's not a good shooter and I
I look at ball more in that light like
folks don't have to score to help his
team win cuz because he's not a great
passer he's not a great defender if he
don't score he's not gonna help the
76ers bow because he's a terrific
defender he's a terrific passer he can
make a difference in the game that's a
great comparison like I like clearly I
like Ben some was a little bit more but
ball can make a difference in the game
but all the other stuff he does even if
you can't shoot talking to Charles
Barkley the Hall of Famer NBA on TNT
analyst if you can only watch one NBA
team this season it would it be it might
be the Oklahoma City Thunder because I
think they're probably I think they got
a chance to being really good that's not
a knock on Camello it just didn't fit
but going out in Dennis Schroder and
going out get Nerlens Noel
I think the Oklahoma City there's no
pressure on Paul George this year they
don't have to have so whether he wants
to be there rust gonna do what Russ does
so other than the Warriors watching
James Harden play I got to be a change
heart to me I said last year might be
the most unguardable NBA player I've
ever seen Michael Jordan was obviously
better Kobe Bryant was obviously better
but from an offensive standpoint I James
I think James Harden it's the most
unguardable NBA player I ever seen but
the answer of course and I'm probably
gonna know what to Oklahoma City Thunder
so if I just said
harden go out and score how many do you
think harden would average Oh
in today's Envy I think I think he could
get 50 wait up at their game because if
it's best if he's making this three you
can't guard him he's gonna get me I mean
the guy's gonna get 15 free throws a
game I really think James Harden could
average 50 points but think about it
he's also Lenalee innocence there yeah I
mean the guy is unguardable it's
supposed to be making that well you know
what he does at the moonwalk we just
like step to the left and right here to
the three
I mean he's unguardable more likely to
leave Golden State after this year
Durant or klay Thompson well I think
it's got to be Durant because to me
they're not gonna be able to pay for
guys
two hundred million dollars that's
what's probably gonna bring a rain or
anything it is because they got to plate
pay clay and Ramon yeah and you can't
pay for guys two hundred million dollars
so I probably think Kevin will leave
because it depends don't they pay those
two gods or those guys take hundreds of
millions of dollar less because they're
all young but like I say you can't have
those guys they said they don't come on
Klay say he'll take a discount three
months and he's not taking at this
company I don't think those guys should
ever take discount I think that's one of
the stupidest things I ever heard these
teams are gonna be around forever
they're all gonna make billions of
dollars I think it's idiotic when I hear
players taking I'm gonna take less money
it's crazy but you have Durant though
who is overly sensitive it feels like
everything bothers him and yeah and I
get the feeling that he's he wanted to
improve his spot on the list of greatest
players of all time that's why he said
you know nobody's gonna vote for me for
Defensive Player of the Year
he feels underappreciated he feels like
he's just as good as LeBron
he's overshadow it's not his team in
Golden State and I just think he gets
one more tight
and then all of a sudden he goes alright
now I'm going to establish something on
my own
and therefore I'm gonna let the NBA fans
fall back in love with me because I'm
gonna do something great for the NBA I'm
gonna leave Golden State and I'll go to
wherever the Knicks can you see that as
a possible scenario well I don't know if
he's mentally tough enough to handle
that you know he's like he's doing Kevin
the Kevin Durant is a great great player
he's a great great kid but he's got
thinner skin and Flat Stanley can you
imagine him in New York City I can't
imagine that yeah because he gives me
he's arguing with high school kids on
Twitter
can you imagine him arguing with the
press in New York they're not winning
how was your summer by the way oh you
know Dan you know what I do I play golf
and I fish every day my golf still sucks
but I'm a really good fisherman any time
you want to go fishing you let me know
Dan I'll take you out there I might try
to drown you can you swim okay I just
want to make sure if we're I like to go
fly-fishing
so I'm actually it's somebody told me I
should learn to go fly-fishing but I
haven't mastered that yet it is it's so
much more difficult than it looks
I think everybody watched that Brad Pitt
movie a river runs through it and said
oh my gosh that looks like it's so much
fun it's it's so tough but when you get
it and you you know you sort of navigate
without putting it in the trees it is
it's just different it's a lot of fun
you put the waiters on you go in there
and that's how men fish Charles not like
you do where you just have a cane pole
and a bobber and then you have a
six-pack of beer yeah I will bet you oh
here we go
$5,000 going to our favorite charity
I'll bet you the Brad Pitt has not been
near a fishing pole since that movie
that was just funny movie but I don't
even know
I'm not gonna take that bet I you could
be right
you could be right but I'm just saying
if maybe I'll go fishing with you one
time because I know even in my my
condition my health condition I could
still be chewed golf listen I think I'm
out of my slump right now no no no no no
no any time you want to play golf you
come on out to Arizona you let me know
brother you can stay at the Berkeley
compound we're good to go
all right how many bedrooms cuz I want
to bring the Dan adds and and I still
want to do a show from your backyard
from the pool area and then we bring in
all your friends from Arizona and we do
a show there four bedrooms but I'm gonna
put you in the guest house oh yeah yeah
I'm gonna put you in the guest house cuz
you know in case you you know you might
got my house of bad habit I don't put
you in the guest house what about the
den ends well listen those guys are
nerds they're not gonna do anything
wrong I guarantee you they all try to go
to bed about nine o'clock at night
they're good dudes okay all right so
they're in the main house yes okay all
right sounds good
all right you know keep stirring it up
there always great to check in with you
we'll talk soon it's a great time with
all the stuff going on right now
basketball football baseball a lot of
fun Thank You Chuck that's Charles
Barkley for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]